Jeffrey was just noting you were talking
about Twitter briefly as we were walking
in and he was noting that when when
Tufte followed him he felt like oh this
is the that's the day I can just you
know sign out I'm done that's the that's
the big deal but when I just started
getting started in visualization about
nine or ten years ago Jeffrey was one of
the academics who is doing things in
visualization at the time and it was
very hard to find people who are doing
things and and also he sort of said
himself apart i think by making his work
very accessible to people outside of the
academic field and so I serve latched
onto him as somebody who was doing stuff
and visualization and I sort of you know
kept him on my radar as someone to watch
and then in October on october third
2012 jeffrey joined twitter i think he
was the last person on the planet to
join Twitter and then on october fifth
he followed me and i was at home and i
was working on my laptop and I was like
oh my gosh Jeffrey here just followed me
and my husband who knows nothing about
Twitter was like well are you gonna
follow him back I don't think he even
knew what that meant and and I said well
you don't not follow Jeffrey here and I
tweeted that of course I had to tweet
that and and then of course I made
Jeffrey blush which I was very proud of
that was proud day for me but I I thank
you jeffrey for reaching out to such a
wide audience for the seminar series i
think it's fantastic and i love watching
the videos of people who have presented
here so just a little bit more about
Paris copic if you don't know who we are
we're a socially conscious data
visualization firm and if you don't know
what data visualization is I'm not sure
why you're here you just want to come
see free talks i guess but data
visualization sort of means different
things to different people and to Paris
copic data visualization means taking
things that are intangible so things
like numbers are statistics things in
databases and and spreadsheets and
making them not only visual invisible
but creating an experience around those
numbers as well so we worked on projects
anywhere from telling stories about the
habitat of polar bears and the threats
to the polar bears because of climate
change or you know the change in how the
warming ocean temperatures affect salmon
populations we worked on projects about
the historical context of income
inequality a wide range of things and
for the past year I've been talking a
lot about our process because it was
really fascinating to me and didn't
really occur to me until about two years
ago that we actually go through a
creative process to do data
visualization so we take these raw
numbers and these things that are really
intangible which is typically done by a
data scientist or a statistician or
somebody a computer programmer somebody
who knows numbers and understands
databases and how to work those things
and how to clean them up and program
around them and then they take them and
make them into something beautiful and
so it didn't really dawn on me that that
was actually a creative process because
I don't think it dawns on most people
that that's a creative process so for
the past year I've been really talking
about how we do that and it's changing
as I learn how we do that we just sort
of do it and we don't really think about
how it's done so I've been sort of
dissecting that and going along and
telling people more and more about how
we do that and then I started really
fixating on the the thing I think at the
core of it and really what happens at
the very genesis of a project which is
we really have to get at the core of
what that data is so the emotional side
of it we have to get back to the data
source and what I mean when I say data
source i don't mean the people gathering
the data and the people who you know are
in the fine print as the data source but
i mean the actual thing that's creating
the data and so you could think of it as
though you know when that data comes to
you you're really sort of far along on
the process
really sort of on like chapter 4 of
where this data has come from right so
there's the what I like to call the
things doing their things which is the
data creation so whatever that is it's
salmon swimming in an ocean it's you
know polar bears dying whatever it's me
it's me standing here my height is 55
that data comes for me I created it the
data doesn't exist without me so that's
really chapter one and that's when you
get to chapter four you're doing the
data visualization all of these things
have come before the data is being
created it's been gathered and parsed
and it's maybe been analyzed hopefully
been analyzed or you do that as part of
the visualization but I think a lot of
people start at chapter four without
really going back and looking at chapter
one and that's really what this talk is
about and and why it's important and how
it really allows us to use data as sort
of a looking glass back into a
connection back into a connection with
that data source so if its people or
animals or whatever the case is or the
environment it allows us to create that
connection and that's how we that's how
I want people to use data and I started
thinking about this about the time a
friend of mine moved down here to the
Bay Area and she and I are terrible at
keeping in contact even when we live
close to each other we both have
children we both have busy lives it's
hard to keep in touch it's hard to you
know pick up the phone and email is
always kind of cumbersome and texting
has this protocol and it was just like
we need a better way of just staying in
touch and so we want to stay in touch
passively we didn't want it to be this
whole protocol based communication and I
was in New York at Google and I visited
with Alexander Chen and he just
offhandedly on his phone was showing me
google latitude and how he uses it with
his wife to make sure that you know
somebody's picking up their daughter
from daycare today and it allowed them
to see you see in real time you know
where the other person was they're
sharing their information and it was
great I was like yes this is exactly
what I need it's totally passive I could
see see my friend and she could see me
and it's it's perfect and so we started
using it and this is this is me and my
little icon there that's our office
Paris copic and the purlin in Portland
so you could see it real time and if I
you know go out and walk down the street
my little icon goes do you did you two
do you end its you know real time it's
nice and simple and easy and I got this
funny sensation once i started using
this that i would go out to lunch or I'd
be walking on the street to run an
errand or something and I kind of felt
like there was this little finger tip on
top of my head as I always walking
around or I felt like there was this
little bird fluttering around me and it
was just this nice sensation that
there's something else out there there's
something else it's a part of this
experience that I'm that's not right
next to me but it's there with me and so
one day not too long after we started
using this I was I was having this
terrible day just everything went wrong
and it was at the end of the day and I
was at home working it was late at night
and i realized that i had left something
at work that was that I needed to get my
work done and I was just like oh so
frustrated it was just the worst day
like nothing could get worse and so I
the kids were in bed my husband was
asleep I didn't wake anybody have to
tell them I was leaving I just got in
the car and I drove back to work and
this is my path back to work and so
right about there I was on i-5 I got on
i-5 south and about 10 seconds after I
did that I get a text from my friend
said keep driving and it was like it
wiped away the whole day because nobody
in the world knew where I was and I had
not even thought about latitude or you
know someone seeing me out there and all
of a sudden there was this connection
with that person and it was just this
this wonderful feeling that just wiped
away all the crummy stuff and what I
realized was that she saw me in these
two numbers a geo coordinate right and
there are two tiny numbers that are just
a dot on a map but she saw me in that
and I felt love through that moment of
these two numbers it enabled a really
emotive moment for us and it allowed us
to see each other and have an experience
just through those two tiny numbers
around the same time than newtown school
shootings happened and I took off my
data hat for a while and I just sort of
turned off I didn't want to see those
people as numbers and then want to think
about the numbers that we're kind of
swirling around that whole tragic event
and I was really hoping that America
could rise above charts and graphs and
just do something and you know just
anything it didn't to me it was like do
we really need a chart or graph to show
us that something is horribly wrong in
our society can't we just move on and
then of course the barrage of charts and
graphs came along and all the bickering
and fighting about all of these issues
and it really was deflating toward to me
and then in the midst of all that this
sort of floating around Twitter and a
friend of mine at Twitter called it that
the chart that broke the camel's back
and to me it was really their chart that
broke the camel's back it was somebody
who would population adjusted mass
shootings in America and his whole he
wrote a whole essay on how you know I
was basically his premise was as long as
mass shootings aren't increasing at a
rate faster than population growth
then that's cool or that's all right
right so this is all idea you know I
don't know maybe some people argue
that's okay to me that's not okay I
don't think it should exist I don't
think we should have to put those words
in the title of a graph I also had a
problem with this graph it was
incredibly dehumanizing it's black and
white and there's no it's a stark as you
can be and so it it really prompted me
to start thinking you know maybe we
should just do something about it my
business partner Dino at the time
tweeted anybody who wants to do a
project about gun visualization or gun
violence let us know will work for free
and nobody contacted us and you know it
was like really let's do something and
everybody in the office was really you
know they wanted to use their skills to
to do something better in the world they
wanted to put our skills to good use so
we started thinking about it and around
that time a good friend of mine Jerome
kooky I who used to work at OECD had
contacted the FBI and gotten these raw
statistics and he sent me this file and
he just i mean just randomly sent it to
me out of the blue and just it the email
was so terse it just said I thought you
might like this and I read the title of
the file and it was homicide 2010 and I
thought that's really disturbing that's
me knows that I would like a file that
had that title um and it but and so I
sat on the file for a while because it
was just it was too much to deal with
and in the midst of all of that horror
but we finally opened it up and and I
worked with FBI data before and I don't
know if any of you have ever worked with
the FBI uniform crime report but it's
really sterile they aggregate everything
up to this absurd degree so you can't
really relate any of the data to each
other I have a real problem with
aggregate data but this data was from
there ni BRS which is the national
incident based reporting system and he
Jerome and filled out a I think alike a
FOIA request or something to get this
and it's every single
homicide in the US and 2010 and when I
looked at it I was like wow that's
amazing we you know we have to do
something with that and we started
talking about it internally and our
office is full of a lot of really
liberal and progressive people and so we
had a lot of very strong opinions is
this should be about gun control and and
then even would think gun control there
were people like it needs to be about
this or needs to be about that and we
started sort of fighting about these
things internally and it was sort of
amazing to me that we could be so
like-minded yet we could be so divisive
as well we weren't really coming
together on anything and it made me
realize that you know this shouldn't be
about one particular thing it shouldn't
be about gun control it shouldn't be
about mental health care whatever the
case may be it really should be about
the victims because that's that's the
data we had and we we had a lot of
information we had their age their race
their gender their their relationship to
the killer we had information about the
killer and what you know what their
demographics were as well we had what
the circumstances were of the killing in
in many cases and so we made a gun
visualization i'm going to show a quick
video of it but i just-i i only want to
preface it by saying we focused just on
all of the people that were killed and
we filtered out everything like anything
that wasn't a gun homicide we felt and
it doesn't have suicides it doesn't have
accidental deaths it's just people who
were killed by guns and so I'll show
quick video of it and I'll explain it a
little bit so basically each line
represents a person and it goes
according to time in a year so this is
January and when a person is killed a
little dot shows up for them tell us
what age they were killed at and then
the gray line is what we predict they
would have died from
if guns hadn't existed so we create sort
of an alternate life for people based on
statistics from the World Health
Organization and so we we figure out in
a probability based on probabilities how
old may they have lived what would they
have died from we have all the causes of
death for every age so we can tell
people would have died from heart
disease or cancer or you know who knows
what they may also have been killed by
you know they may have been killed by
another person as well by without guns
but it's kind of heartbreaking to sit
there and watch it all play out you have
to sit there quite a while and it goes
super super fast and then we explored
the distribution of of this violence and
it's very striking to see over here are
the people who died from guns and on the
gray side are the people who you know
that's what their alternate life could
have been and we have filters for
filtering by ethnicity or bi bi sex you
can roll over a line and find out all
the details about that person that we
had it's a white man who was shot at age
20 during an argument we can filter by
you know children these are all twelve
percent of these people were kids they
were kids who were 18 or younger it's
kind of striking to see that and you
could see each individual child up there
and find out more about them this is
particularly horrifying to me the
multiple victim killings because the
federal government defines mass
shootings as an incident that involves
four or more killings which doesn't even
make it onto the nightly news in most
cases you know it has to be eight or ten
people these days before it makes the
news and we hear about these things
filtering by rifle different types of
gun types as well but the thing when
local killings is that you when we
looked at the data there were tons of
incidents that were
you know two-person killings or
three-person killings and a lot of them
were familial you know a person a child
in their mother shot by father or vice
versa two children killed by one of
their parents or a caregiver it was it's
really heartbreaking when you look at
these specific details and you start to
get that connection back to each and
every one of these people and it's not
just a dot on a line and now it's not
just part of a bar chart you actually
see each individual person in this
visualization and we really wanted again
for this not to be about a specific
cause or you know we're trying to you
know carry the torch for gun control I
would love it if people just threw away
their guns I mean I am probably the most
liberal person who worked on this and
you know I was like let's just take all
the guns away let's read e to do that so
it was it about you know driving people
towards one action it was really about
opening people's eyes and hoping that
they would make any action in their
lives so maybe this could open up
something in them the emotive part of
this could let them see into something
else see into an actual life and see
that maybe they could make some change
they could do something in their own
world they could become more involved in
their community maybe they can become a
big brother big sister maybe they could
intervene when they start to see the
warning signs of domestic violence maybe
they could just not turn a blind eye if
they start to see something that's
giving them a red flag you know and
that's really what we're hoping with all
of these things is that it doesn't take
a bunch of people with huge actions two
questions the first is if the goal is
kind of behavior change interest why the
focus on the kind of
statistics and identity politics of the
victim versus the killer vs been a
cross-correlation yeah we focused on the
victim primarily because we felt that
had the most impact it was about the
loss of life we felt like we were
showing you know there's a huge loss of
potential and that's why we put the
years of stolen life up here and it was
more about look at this the tragedy of
it wasn't so much about let's get angry
at these killers and we hope that you
know by certain we're changing in a bit
too we're going to add in more filters
down here but by using things like gun
type that are you know will lead people
to certain conclusions about you know
gun control they can start to have more
of an opinion about the the factors that
go into it but we felt that by focusing
on the victims and showing that loss of
potential that was really our goal was
to show you know their babies that would
never grow old their kids who are headed
college who had so much left to do in
life and that was you know what we were
trying to trigger with people my second
question had to it also this notion of
identity politics of kind of
intersectionality which talks about how
difference like you have the different
dimensions of it be kinda interrelate
and correlate I'm curious from the
information visualization perspective
know the stories that you mentioned are
intersectional story about someone at a
specific age for in their lives like I
thought about how you might be able to
use fists and then tell these more
intersectional stories instead of
looking at it just / dimensional pieces
yeah that's really an interesting take
on it I think that some of the features
that we're adding to it and might get
more at what you're getting towards
we're adding in live data for 2013 it's
going to be released in a couple of
weeks it's if you want to visit it its
guns Paris kappa calm and we'll be
rolling out those features soon but it
will allow you to sort of look at a few
different factors that go into the
lives so you can really get into
specifics about you know specific
demographics or specific situation so
that might get more at what you're
talking about but I'd love to discuss
that more sure your ideas on well we
were going through this project though a
lot of there was a lot of discussion
about the language we were using because
we tend to hide behind words a lot will
tend to use fancier words or more
clinical terms for things if they just
sound bad we don't want to we don't want
to talk about people being killed we
want to talk about homicides because
that's easier that sounds like something
I spray on my crops in the summertime
yeah and you know we really challenged
ourselves to use real words and plain
language if you've seen the Economist
writing style guide we really tried to
use that as our as our guide moving
through this project it's talks a lot
about using plain language and it talks
about how to talk about numbers and it
gets at a very human level of speech at
language and at numbers which was really
inspirational for us I encourage people
to read that if they do any writing and
so we we really challenged ourselves to
to focus on the actual words because you
know if we hide behind those words it's
really we're shielded our selves from
those emotions and the emotions are
really what we need to get at these
problems and start making these changes
and I mean it happens in every field
practically anything that has anything
tough to deal with my oldest son was
diagnosed with cancer when he was nine
months old and they use a lot of words
that are really big and fancy and you
know they when they were diagnosing him
they said oh he has an effer blastoma
and I was like okay great does that is
that something that helped him get into
Yale or
what is that they're like no that's
kidney cancer oh ok well just tell me
that or you know loss of heterozygosity
I was like oh great he has a loss of it
we don't want that heterozygosity and I
know you want that that's a tumor
suppressor oh well that's kind of crazy
and it wasn't until you know he was in
surgery and it was you know the day
after all this blew up and they had only
seen pictures of his cancer through MRIs
and x-rays and so they were going in to
to assess what was actually happening
with his kidneys and see what was
happening for the first time and so we
were waiting in a waiting room and if
you've ever had somebody go through
surgery there's this big waiting room
where all the families and loved ones
sit and so we're in the waiting room and
the surgeon comes in and they take us to
a smaller room you do not wanna go to
the smaller room trust me it's a very
nice comfy room it's kind of like your
house is comfortable and it's low
lighting and you immediately become
suspicious because it's like the person
that's too nice to your like way being
nice to me it's like why is there this
nice room in the hospital and it's a
feel right I don't want to be here and
the doctor said the surgeon said we have
to remove Williams right kidney and we
have to remove thirty percent of his
left kidney and it was like there was a
nuclear bomb that went off on all these
words it was like they just were
completely obliterated and I suddenly
was like that's all I need to know you
know we have the plan of action was
already sort of set in course there's
nothing I mean I could have said no you
can't take that out I mean you wouldn't
want to do that because you die so
there's like a protocol that had to be
followed but it was it sort of enabled
me to see what was happening you know
make that connection through those words
like it enabled me to stabilize myself
and my emotions because now I knew what
it was it was real and I can move
forward so those words really helped me
and they were just plain simple words
and they were the bluntest words I've
ever heard anybody say this is the most
depressing talk EULA
it's going to get worse I'm sorry all I
know there are a lot of students here
getting credit for this and you're
working for it today so this is not fun
stuff then I'm but as I was thinking
about language I realized there are also
words that we try to hide we try to hide
these words we try to stuff them in a
dark closet and get away from them as
much as we can nobody talks about this
word nobody says rape unless your woman
and especially if you're a young woman
you'll probably you know and I'm talking
to your friends about it because it's
rape as a women's issue right which is
kind of ironic because it's not at all
women's issue it's a man's issue for the
most part for the most part there is a
percentage that of women who do rip but
but generally speaking this has become a
women's issue and I mean I've never
heard men talk about rape and once I
force them to talk about it which is
pretty interesting and I find that they
really don't have a grasp of how to
think about it and it was kind of
profound to me but it's a word that sort
of only comes up when women are in a
group of a safe group of other women you
know and maybe a small group of friends
or relatives or whatever and usually
comes up around you know somebody's
daughter is going to college or gee I
moved into a new area or I moved into
this apartment and I'm not sure it's
safe and you know sort of these issues
that we all have to deal with and so I
was at dinner one night with some
friends of mine and we got started
talking about rape and sexual assault
because of I don't even remember what it
was at the time and we were like we were
sort of frustrated by the fact that it
was such a hidden word and nobody talked
about it and nobody really and we also
were feeling like kind of loss like we
didn't have enough information to really
navigate our worlds and so we said you
know we were getting all riled up and we
said why can't we just put a sign up for
every rape that's happened in the city
and suddenly the room got quiet
maybe we could we could put a sign up
for every rape in the city that's kind
of bizarre and so they said Kim you're
the data person go find that out so I
went out and found that in fact we could
find all the rapes in the city and it
was pretty amazing this is well before
Paris gothic that started this is you
know before I realized I was into data
visualization so Portland police puts
out all of their crime reports and this
was back at 2002 which was pretty
remarkable for the time they put it all
on mine it was freely accessible and
completely open so I said fantastic we
all got together and i said here's the
data i have got the neighborhood and I
have a date and I said we have a
neighborhood in a date are you kidding
me that's like the most sparse
information you could ever get about
anything but to me it was so rich
because that neighborhood i know that
neighborhood because i live in that city
and I know the coffee shop that I go to
you in that neighborhood and I date I
can look up on my calendar and I could
say oh I had coffee with Ted that day
and oh by the way someone was very 20
blocks away from me so it suddenly was
like very rich and personal and when I
look back at that file every time I
would open it up it was like those gates
were just screaming at me there was
there was this connection coming in
through that data that was just
screaming at me to do something with it
and so we did we went out we made signs
for every rape in the city and it seems
kind of insane right now looking back at
it but we did it and you know we didn't
have the gender of the person we didn't
have any specifics we just had this
picture is pretty poor but there's
actually a very light map on the back
behind the words and so it shows the
neighborhood that it's in and we drove
around in my friends camry late at night
with hammers and we pounded these things
into the ground and it was amazing to
see what happened because when you bring
that data out into the world and you
sort of force it on people
the scales fall from people's eyes they
were just I mean it the response was
really amazing people would run after us
down the street and say are you kidding
me this happened in my neighborhood how
do you know this and who was it and what
happened and they wanted to know
everything most of the times we just say
I don't know anything more than what the
sign says but but yes it happened and it
was making that that horrible incident
this visible to people people would hug
us people would come up and like want it
tell us their life stories of people
would come up and tell us about the rape
stories too it was pretty amazing people
will cry I remember a specific incident
where we were walking on the street and
these two huge guys both walking each
walking a pitbull they look like
linebackers if I had been alone on the
street I would have walked the other
direction and they they have been like
reading the signs than they came over to
us and they were like what like they
were so stunned and so stymied I didn't
even like to know what questions to ask
they were like is this real like they
were in a different world or something
that were like is this real well I guess
it's real and yeah we got the data from
the Portland Police Bureau and these are
all actual dates I mean they were just
they couldn't even wrap their heads
around it and it was so shocking to me
that these two men who like I mean I
think they were just so into their own
world that they just may never occurred
to them to think about that so to me it
was fantastic I mean they talked to us
for about 15 minutes about it and it was
wonderful I was great to make that
connection with somebody I would
probably never ever would have connected
with on this topic any other way and it
was just amazing and my hope is that
those people will you know these are two
huge guys with pit bulls hopefully they
will now be watchdogs for their
neighborhood maybe they will you know
spot something before it happens maybe
they'll educate their friends I don't
know what will happen I don't know what
did happen with them but hopefully you
know hopefully that carries
on into the world but the data really
again it just allows us to make these
connections back to people and that is
like a tiny tiny bit of little bitty
information that we just put into the
world there was a woman who came up to
us and said told us her rape story and
she said I want to put one of these
signs in the ground and we said
fantastic have at it and she took a
hammer and she obliterated that sign
that day in shreds it was amazing and it
really it gave her an opportunity to
fight back you know and that I mean
those kind of connections wouldn't
couldn't have made them any other way
and well I don't consider this you know
part of my visualization portfolio when
I look back on it it really is
visualization it's taking something
that's intangible a date a map something
sort of abstract and it's bringing it
back into the real world it's enabling
an experience this is a project that's
not not my own project but it's a really
beautiful project it's by a group called
Project ak-47 and I have one of these
necklaces but I couldn't find it I think
my children stole it from me but it's
basically this project works with
rescuing kids from their lives of being
child soldiers around the world and they
as part of their outreach they have
these dog tags that you can get and
these aren't real dog tags of course
these kids don't walk around with dog
tags none of these guerrilla armies are
that sophisticated to actually issue dog
tags but what they do is they take these
very recognizable us dog tags and put
the information of the child on it so
the child's name is Ishmael has he's
male he's 12 years old and he's a child
soldier in the Philippine Army it
becomes very real and when I wear mine
the dog tags are right next to my heart
and it's extremely emotional whenever I
wear them and it's such a beautiful
incarnation of that data I think it's
just one of my favorite projects about
data this is thoroughly depressing and I
apologize so I'm going to give you a
little reprieve here for a minute this
is my one happy slide and actually it's
not all that happy there is really sad
poor thing it was cute though ah but i
did i do want to talk a little bit about
you know it's not all doom and gloom I
feel like sometimes at Paris copic you
know people are walking in like oh my
god do we really have to look at people
dying and polar bears getting shot and
Sam and who can't breed and you know all
these horrible things we're thundery so
here at Stanford one of them I guess
other institutions which I was written
style there's a kind of struggle in
terms of data Providence and accuracy
against an organization so example
Stanford won't necessarily report
numbers on a per year basis around for
space basis because you know they say
that it would
be stepping too far in terms of both
anonymity and also asking things of the
victim some curious if you've seen
people that have tried to instead of
relying on self-report there's only
those are 12 report you know using an
adjustable inference on pure report so
instead asking the community to report
how many of your peers that experience
texts as a way of uncovering kind of
missing data essentially that is
inherent it's all these data sets so
write exams is the answer yeah that's a
very good point especially with things
like rape and you know there's such a
you know there's a still a stigma
surrounding rape and there's a lot of
fear with reporting and I mean there are
so many issues that go into that for
this piece we felt like we wanted to
stay true to the actual real data that
we had just so we could make it real
about a specific incident but we did do
another project on rape that was an
online piece and it was all based on
statistics and it was based on cystic
statistics from the rain organization
which is probably the leading
organization that deals with rape and
sexual assault and they do a lot of that
internally to get at their statistics to
figure out you know even though a small
percentage are reported they're through
with their research they've found that
you know a rape happens once every two
minutes that you know one and if six
women will be raped in her lifetime that
sort of thing and one in 33 men I don't
want to discount that either so we did
do a piece on that and we also sort of
took it even though we had just these
broad statistics we created a story out
of that as well so we sort of created an
incident based on statistics so we sort
of humanized it in a sort of a reverse
way so we knew things like what type of
we we tied in rain statistics with the
FBI's Uniform Crime Report and they do
have things like what weapon was used if
any what kind of self defense was used
if any and if it
helped what kind of weapon was used if
any I can't remember get to all the
distinct things but but there were about
six data points that we had and so we
created a little story about each
hypothetical person and you know we had
their gender we and so it made it
actually was really beautiful because it
made things like the the number of men
who are raped which is you know a small
number but and we tend to dismiss it if
we see it as just a percentage you know
if we see it as just six percent or
whatever it is it's such a small number
we can just dismiss it but when we
created is real story out of it he was
raped by his friend and you know under
these circumstances in his dorm room and
blah blah it suddenly makes those small
numbers real numbers even if it's a you
know something that we could easily
dismiss otherwise so so yeah I think
that's really an important point to
consider and in terms of you know what
you're trying to get across and you know
is it the numbers or is it you know
trying to be true to a specific type of
data there are a lot of portions that
can go into it in terms of messages and
I comic common tactic in some work is
the kind of care consciousness-raising
and calls to action so looking at your
kind of embodied visualization in the
world I'm curious if you thought about
is the pair that call that machine
within that this visible reputation for
example if you have QR codes that
connect to something or even kind of
crowd-sourced thing you know would how I
think would it be or what is it
transformative or healing in some way
for someone to take a sign and say
feeling like I was raped here or and
then put that there how's it shakin on
the team I love those ideas they're all
great um yeah I mean this was in 2002
before the word cross which
crowdsourcing existed but I mean I would
have loved to continue the project and
done some of those things I mean those
are wonderful creative ideas and that's
I
that's getting exactly to what this talk
is about it's like how do you make that
connection with people through those
through that data through the statistics
you know do you engage them through some
active measure do you give them a way to
get more information so how do you
enable that sort of two-way street
through the data I think those are all
fantastic ideas and sort of tie into you
know the other hypotheticals that you
know is getting out like this is
completely depressing and we focus on a
lot of sad stuff but we could also talk
about things like what didn't happen you
know what are the missing pieces that
you know rape has gone down
significantly since we did this project
in 2002 we could take and create
different signs for the reps that have
been prevented you know and we could say
talk about why they were prevented and
i'm not sure what the reasons are and
i'm not sure anybody does but we could
talk about you know better policing or
better education for boys and men better
self defense classes for women and girls
you know we could talk about those
things through those instances as well
it doesn't always have to be just
focusing on the completely bad and
horrible stuff the gun visualization we
could use it to show you know if gun
measures are passed what change do they
have do they affect things do people now
get to live their lives or for cancer
research can we use it to to show how
many lives have been saved due to cancer
research my own son is now five year old
and he's happy and healthy due to
fantastic pediatric cancer research now
there's a full protocol for his type of
kidney cancer it was like they just
checked it off the list and he's done
and at home and happy so we can use
visualizations in lots of different ways
and we could show the avenues for for
change you know if we have that
information about how to change things
or changes that we've made and the
effect that they've had let's allow
people to see that as well so that they
can take that away and so maybe that's
something I want to get involved with or
maybe that's something I want to support
because I see what an effect it has and
also getting back to those two data
points
my friend and I know the gia coordinate
but right now you know I'm a bad on a
map right now I'm shifting slightly i'm
not sure if my little numbers are
changing all that much if you're swaying
back and forth but i generally am at
rest here i'm a little dot on a map at
rest but that day I was a dot in motion
about 90 miles an hour down a deserted
freeway at midnight you know and it's
just thinking about what what kinds of
things does this enable you know what
other ways can we look at that data how
do we make those connections and oops
you know so maybe those my friend and I
are two dots in a map yes but maybe we
are maybe there's like a rubber band
that sort of constricts the world to us
maybe we are just fixed in place and
we're as close as we are and our
relationship is what the two dots
represents and maybe the the map
constricts and constraints to suit our
relationship or maybe it's the angle
that's created when the two of us look
at the moon maybe it's the you know
something else in the in the far
distance that's between us but it
somehow creates this tiny tiny tiny
number instead of those two dots maybe
there's this tiny number that helps
diminish that space between us and so I
just want to end with again that we all
if we're working with data we have the
power to go back to that chapter one to
see what those the things doing their
things what are they doing and how do we
connect to that I know it's easy as data
people as computer people we like to
fall in love with those numbers i know i
do whenever I open up in a database or
data set I immediately fall in love with
the numbers I see the shape I see the
relationships and I like to play with
that but I also have to remind myself to
take that step back and say well this
actually came from somewhere this didn't
just this is on my desktop is not the
genesis of this it happened somewhere
way back here maybe it was last week
maybe it was two years ago
or 15 years ago but it came from
somewhere and so we all have the power
to go back to it get at that information
get out that connection and that's
really where we can start to make magic
happen thank you yes I mean the room had
to be struck by the flatness and just
use an old phrase the banality of evil
kind of a characterized that flat file
you had on the gun dust right and then
that transformation you showed with kind
of using the social graph and figuring
out you know that the arcs that were
interrupted is really really striking
did that get you like right away when
you saw that file or was there a lot of
work to kind of get that it's very
powerful visualization what did it take
you to get there it's a good question
and that really varies from project to
project for this specific one it came
very fast actually I was I had been you
know doing some other unrelated stuff
that was really inspirational to me at
the time and when we sat down and looked
at these numbers and like I said it sort
of opened up a can of worms internal
ages between even us like-minded folks
and people were becoming divisive and
saying I and we should do this we should
do that and a lot of people wanted to a
great the stuff to show certain things
and to make a certain point and and it's
sort of like to me was almost like there
was this cloud that kept getting bigger
and bigger and it just kept getting
Messier and Messier and I don't remember
exactly what it was but somebody had
said something that triggered this idea
for me that it was this loss there was a
loss and so it just when I heard that
and it was like yeah it was like that's
obvious it's that some what this is
about it's about this loss and I don't
know where the art came from it just it
seemed like it's sort of this natural
way of looking at a life there's a
beginning there's an apex there's a
there's a death so it just seemed like a
natural way to show that perhaps and we
we did play around with the number of
other ideas as well you know showing
things as lines or other you know
straight lines or you know other little
like Wiggly things and whatnot and but
none of them just really felt all that
natural and and this really struck
people and when we added this the intro
is really i think what sealed it for
everybody is seeing those first five
deaths that we use to just sort of
explain things and the drug but the dot
that drops down is that was just like
okay this is done that's exactly what it
is most projects we have aren't don't
have that clarity i think one thing that
helped this project was that the data
set was really small you know is really
less than 10,000 rows with less than you
know 20 data points to it i think um and
that really helps us and that's what I
try to do on on projects in general is
if we have a lot of data if we have just
this massive amount of crazy data I
often try to chop things into manageable
pieces and just take it like a subset of
data and focus on just that so I don't
muddy the water and then just come up
with some idea for that and then
extrapolate out into the rest of it if I
can but having something finite is
really it really helps you to sort of
constraint things and you can come up
with like a single metaphor for things
so they basically moving top is really
that's directed oh I just it seems like
a lot of this is about drilling down
individual sort of make it really human
scale do the people's work to see the
data and thanks i'm going to talk about
massive datasets a point aggregation is
necessary so
talk about some attention there what you
can get out of the more I available
substitution yeah angra it is tough I
really don't like working with it it's
not only because it's you can't connect
back to that incident but because it
removes those relationships so if I say
eighty percent of black people this and
twenty percent of women this I have no
way of knowing if how those twenty
percent of women relate to those eighty
percent of black people you know are
they all the 27 or twenty percent within
that age center they scattered around
you've been lead astre buted I don't
know so when you aggregate you lose so
much it's just it's heartbreaking to me
I hate hate using aggregate data but
again I mean the other ray project I was
describing did take that aggregate data
and we sort of did a reverse on it and
and took those numbers and created a
specific it's specific incident based on
you know just you know choosing based on
those statistics you know oh seven
percent of these incidents have gone so
seven percent of these stories will have
a gun in them and so we created this
fictitious story but it's all based on
statistics so so that's one tactic and
you know it doesn't always have to be
about an incident that's not always the
way to get at people I mean you can do
simple things like I mean even the
showing something like this I mean just
the color alone changing that can really
have an impact like an emotional impact
so it's not that you have to say this
specific thing happened to this specific
person and this is how you should feel
about it sometimes it's just you know
what you do with the color or the
metaphor or the design we did a project
for about voter education called vote
easy and it's wildly popular people love
it and all it is is this to row of yard
signs like political yard signs so when
somebody is running for office you put
out a sign so and so for Congress and so
it's a you plug in your zip code and and
it
comes up with all these signs of all the
people who are running for office in
here Aaron this is only on election year
obviously but and then it it allows you
to answer like ten questions how do you
feel about abortion or guns or
Afghanistan at Bubba and as you're
answering them these yard signs are like
coming towards you or they're going away
and it's very you could very quickly
figure out like oh this person is like
me and that's why it's they're coming
towards me and then you know they're
more important based on line my issues
but it's incredibly emotional too
because people will be like oh wait I
don't like that guy I had I don't wait
he's coming towards me I could change my
answer you know and it's amazing how
people get connected that way and it's
just based on you know well how do you
feel and how do these people feel and
it's it's not about like a specific
instance of something it's more of a you
know and these are all very broad topics
and but it's somehow connecting through
those numbers in kind of a fun way as
well as you know an easy-to-understand
way it somehow makes it fun and
enjoyable and lets people see things
that they didn't we had a number of
people write to us and say I had no idea
that this green party guy was running
and to that exact exactly what I wanted
and now i'm going to go vote for them
and you know otherwise i wouldn't have
voted some guy wrote to us and said I
wasn't you know I didn't ever care about
voting and now I just registered to vote
it was amazing so it's you can find
those avenues back to people and make
those connections through other ways as
well so that project sounds pretty cool
first off but I had another another
question so it seems like a lot of your
work is around charts to persuade people
of things and I've read a lot of
criticism that like charts in that area
often do things that are kind of
misleading bike you know bar charts
where they wanna miss nosey row so it
looks like things have when really
there's just variations but their ethics
associated with yes I mean we try to be
as rigid about that as we can I mean
we're strong proponents of following the
ethics of you know not you know we
follow we know all of those books and we
read you only have all the books and
about how to do things properly and
we've studied that since day one you
know we know all of those things about
starting at zero on how to scale and all
those things and area versus you know
whatever and so yeah I mean all of those
things come into play for sure and we're
very strict about that we also will
point it out if we see somebody else who
has misbehaved and we like to out those
people on Twitter and on our blog so
yeah I mean we're very thorough about
that and then they're jamming there will
always be I you know misleading is you
know one category and then there's just
like changing perceptions you know and
and guiding people in a certain way and
I mean a lot of these causes yeah we
want people to come away with a certain
message does that mean we're misleading
I don't think we're misleading with
numbers but we are definitely looking
for a certain type of response so for
instance if you know the we did a piece
on salmon we want people to know that
these salmon are dying and why they're
dying and why their populations are
falling off and that its relation
related to ocean temperature you know
those numbers are represented very
fairly and honestly but through design
you can also compel people you know you
compel people to action and show them
you know here's our message it's not
evil to have a message or have a stance
on what the data is telling you right if
that's what you're getting at so throw
your thought that I felt that what
you're doing is not getting back to the
roots of the data but getting back to
how people relate to the data so it
seemed like with those science 30 signs
for instance we have you are physically
in that place or it's much better to
connect do with that piece of data
similarly when you show people's ages
and what they could have lived
that it's much easier to connect to them
as you know people rather than dogs on
the screen right so I wonder you know
but what we what you want to do here
it's not getting you the roots of the
data but get back to how people relate
to it is that a fair take away from here
what you can you say that lesson it is
it fair to say the egg away from for me
for this job is you know connect back to
how people relate to the data rather
than connect back to how the data was
generated um yes I would say that's
that's true I mean if we're gonna if I
was going to say I how the data was
generated in a in the case of rape yeah
I don't want to I don't want to be at
that specific moment in time but yes I
want to connect people back to that that
person and that I mean as close as I can
get them to relate back to you know what
was happening there in the circumstances
surrounding it not so much about how
that data was that came to be I mean
that is kind of a theoretical question
as well like well what data exists you
know the data come first or the data
source conversor you know everything is
data I always see data all around me all
these seats have data you know every
single Dottin the planet has data but
it's really like what is that emotive
point of that of that data and you know
what happened there who was that person
or what was that thing that happened I
mean it doesn't have to be all human and
you know like a lot of the stuff i was
talking with about people but it could
be about a roadway or it could be about
a glacier or you know it could be about
a lot of other things inanimate objects
but you can still get back to that you
know what is that data saying to you how
does it relate to your life you know a
lot of our work is about you know
telling things about the environment and
how do we how do we frame that in terms
of you know someone's life and you know
a lot of these things they see it as
like this miniscule number across a
chart and so long big deal i'm going to
be long
before that has any impact on me so it's
you know you have to start finding ways
to to make that relatable and make that
apparent to people on it so that's more
of what I'm talking about I guess is
that that type of connection do you ever
think about Oh kind of saying you know
you probably have a frequent supposition
about the data without to show you then
you show something that's relatively
denying non concerning etc and then go
to a more rich visualization much like
you did with the gunshots think well
that's one way to look at it but
actually these are this is kind of your
aggregated argument right here's what
the aggregated data tells you but here's
what the individual stories are do you
ever find that be persuasion that's
interesting i'm not sure that we've done
a project like that that's a good
question that's a really interesting
would i would like to do something like
that now that you've given me that idea
i'll probably steal it that's a really
interesting point we are doing one
project the one that we're doing on
income inequality deals a little bit
with that it was kind of a tough project
because it's a lot of statistics and
models and things that aren't you know
with models in particular it's very
difficult to you know show that in any
other way than just here's the
prediction you know the next 30 years
but we try to humanize it through
illustration so we showed for instance
um you could we have like a demographic
breakdown of income inequality so we
have by race and by gender and whatnot
and so you know we gave us a bar chart
you know a grouped bar chart of you know
here are the education levels and the
race and the gender and here's how they
all break down and you can find yourself
in a little bar chart like oh that's me
I'm a white woman with you know
bachelor's degree you papa that's where
I sit but that's really not at all
emotional but we just did basically the
same thing but we just Illustrated it so
we put a person on top of each of the
bars and made it nice and pretty of
course a bit
we so we so people could identify like
Oh that that's me that could be me up
there and then when the male figure
comes in it says I you know I make seven
thousand more because I male and then
the Asian woman comes in and she says I
make nine thousand for me as an Asian or
something you know and so you start to
see like oh wow this is real these are
real people these are you know that's me
up there and I'm represented and so it
starts to get at more of that and it
goes to the design question again that
you know a lot of different design
factors can lead to that emotion as well
that's probably as close as we've got to
do something like that but I like that
idea any other questions thank our
speaker
you